FLORIDA HOME.
JOINING US NOW CNN CONTRIBUTOR
AND FORMER NIXON WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL JOHN DEAN.
JOHN, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
THIS IS PURELY AN
EXTRAORDINARILY RARE MOVE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IN YOUR DECADES OF LEGAL WORK
SERVING AS PRESIDENT NIXON'S
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL, HAVE YOU
EVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS?
>> NOTHING.
IT WAS ACTUALLY A BRILLIANT MOVE
GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHAT TRUMP DID IS HE TOOK HIS
RIGHT OF PRIVACY ABOUT WHAT WAS
GOING ON, JUST AS HE WAS SERVED
A SUBPOENA HE TOLD NOBODY WHEN
HE HAD A SEARCH AT HIS PROPERTY.
HE COULD HAVE TOLD NOBODY, BUT
HE DECIDED THE OPPOSITE.
HE PUT OUT A REALLY DUPIOUS
PRESS RELEASE WHERE HE ATTACKED
THE INSTITUTION AND HE LAID
DOUBT ABOUT THE PROCESS AND I
THINK IT WAS A FOOLISH MOVE AND
IT WILL COME BACK AND BITE HIM,
WOLF.
>> TRUMP SAYS HIS ATTORNEYS AND
REPRESENTATIVES WERE COOPERATING
FULLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE FBI.
DOES THEIR REFUSAL TO UNSEAL
THIS WARRANT LEAD YOU TO BELIEVE
THAT'S THE TRUTH?
>> WELL, THAT COULD NOT BE THE
TRUTH.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, MERRICK
GARLAND IS NOT THE KIND OF MAN
WHO WOULD GO TO THIS EXTREME
MEASURE AS HE SAID IN HIS
SPEECH.
HE WOULD USE A MORE FRIENDLY
PROCESS TO GET THE JOB DONE, BUT
THEY WERE CLEARLY NOT RESPONDING
TO A FRIENDLY PROCESS AND THAT'S
WHY THEY TOOK THE EXTREME ACTION
THEY HAD TO TAKE AND FROM THE
REPORTING INDICATES THIS WAS
PROBABLY TOP-SECRET INFORMATION
THAT TRUMP HAD SQUIRRELLED AWAY
AND REFUSED TO TURN OVER.
TOP SECRET IS VERY IMPORTANT.
IT ISN'T CLASSIFIED THAT WAY
UNLESS THERE'S AN EXPECTATION
THAT IT CAN CAUSE EXCEPTIONAL
DAMAGE TO THE NATIONAL SECURITY.
WOLF, THAT'S SERIOUS AND THAT'S
WHY THEY MOVED TO GET IT BACK IN
THEIR CUSTODY.
>> FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
TRIED TO DRAW PARALLELS BETWEEN
THE SEARCH IN MAR-A-LAGO IN
FLORIDA AND THE BREAK-IN AT
WATERGATE AS YOU KNOW WELL.
AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT THIS
SEARCH AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S DESIRE FOR THE
DOCUMENTS TO BE UNSEALED, DOES
THAT COMPARISON HOLD UP?
>> IT'S PATHETIC.
IT SHOWS HE HAS NO KNOWLEDGE OF
WHAT HAPPENED WITH WATERGATE.
WATERGATE WAS MUCH MORE THAN A
BREAK-IN, OF COURSE.
IT WAS A COVER-UP AND IT WAS
MORE NIXON'S ABUSE OF POWER AND
YOU KNOW SOMETHING, WOLF?
NIXON WAS AN INSTITUTIONALIST.
HE WOULDN'T ATTACK THE FBI AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IN THE
BLATANT AND BLIND WAY THAT TRUMP
IS.
HE KNEW THOSE PEOPLE.
MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE TRUMP HAS
NEVER BEEN IN WASHINGTON OR
WORKED WITH THE PEOPLE OR REALLY
KNOWN THEM AND THESE ARE
HARDWORKING PEOPLE WHO REALLY
HAVE THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
COUNTRY IN MIND.
SO I THINK TRUMP'S ATTACKS ARE
SO FAR OFF BASE AS ARE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> HOW DO YOU SEE THIS PLAYING
OUT, JOHN?
ANY CHANCE THE FEDERAL JUDGE
DOESN'T GRANT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S REQUEST?
>> WELL, IF TRUMP MAKES A STRONG
CASE ON PRIVACY, THE JUDGE MIGHT
HEAR HIM OUT, BUT I THINK THAT'S
A BAD POSITION FOR TRUMP TO BE
IN TO MAKE ALL THESE CLAIMS AND
THEN KEEP IT SECRET.
SO HE'S BETWEEN A ROCK AND A
HARD PLACE TODAY, AND I THINK
THE JUDGE WOULD OBVIOUSLY LIKE
TO RELEASE IT SINCE THE
GOVERNMENT IS THE ONE THAT ASKED
THAT IT BE SEALED AND NOW
THEY'RE ASKING UNSEAL IT.
AGAIN, THIS IS